this is star talk cosmic queries edition
and we've titled this one
fermentation
and flavor science
welcome chuck
man how are you buddy always good to
have you
i don't people know you're my co-host in
star talk sports edition that's right
you're quite the sports weenie i have
come to learn
that's a compliment
i'm not sure you know when you the word
sports and weenie don't really go to the
truth that's true you can be weather
weenie yeah yeah
okay
no i like sports weenie i'm gonna be
that
no we need a we need an alliterative
thing because whether we need alliterate
so right sports i'll find something else
for you okay cool but uh this is about
just about food and and what role
fermentation plays i am a big fan of
fermentation of fermented food and
well
[Laughter]
neither of us has expertise in this but
we got someone from this dark talk
rolodex yeah dr ariel johnson ariel
welcome back to star talk thanks so much
for having me back i think you were last
on the show in a live
uh star talk live what i think was in
new york city town hall i believe it was
yeah well excellent well thanks for
thanks for coming back and thanks for
having me back and we did a whole show
on food let me remind people who you are
if you didn't either attend or uh see
that episode you have a phd in
agricultural and environmental chemistry
which is this is true very cool i'm glad
it's true thank you for verifying
uh our crack team of researchers
good job
our investigative reporters found this
about you your science officer for good
eats on the food network and you're a
food writer with stuff published in the
lucky peach i think l.a times and
there's one here called mold magazine
that's a magazine it's a it's a
speculational magazine about the future
of food so if you're into uh food or
design it's a pretty excellent quite
frankly i don't think you're speculating
when you call it mold that's just
something it's like i'm not picking up
that magnet
all food will eventually in the future
exactly
there's no there's no speculation there
all food
as opposed there might be an element of
the uh the hominins of uh mold mold
being fungus and being molding like a
verb yeah there you go right molding all
right let me let me lead off with a
question here so
i think in modern times where we have
modern means of preservation i think we
might have lost track or lost
understanding
of
how fermented foods ever made their way
into our diet in the first place
right and so you know why do we have
cheese well
if i under if i know my history
correctly this was a
product of like fermented
proteins in a milk or whatever milk
products that
that would last longer than the milk
itself in the closet
so how much is it basically all of
fermentation was just to preserve food
is this a fair characterization of it
all
yeah i mean
um most fermentation processes do
preserve food um often by adding acids
to them or uh killing off
less desirable bacteria and
microorganisms
um one thing
because i
the desirable bacteria right yeah yeah
the uh the undesirable bacteria is not
so good for you
um you know your uh your uh
norovirus which is a virus um obviously
or your uh you know various spoilage
spoilage molds and yeasts
um not so tasty but i mean one one thing
i like a way that i like to think about
fermentation is that like
you know back in
uh probably not that far back in history
but pre uh
pre-refrigeration and you know even even
pre-agriculture
um
most food would ferment pretty quickly
uh so if you if you milk milk your cow
or your goat or whatever sort of a
ruminant animal you have hanging around
your your village or your campsite um
that milk is gonna start fermenting
pretty quickly um
so
vegetables likewise if you uh
if you pick them and store them for a
while we'll start fermenting same with
same with grapes or fruit things like
that um so so when i think of
fermentation i think of
the sugar
like i can't think of fermented string
beans but i can think of a fermented
grape or a fruit so how do you ferment
things that don't have sugar in them
well string beans actually have sugar in
them so most vegetables have like
anywhere between like two and even up to
like 15 sugar for like my mama never
told me that string beans had sugar
otherwise
just a little bit
maybe that's why my mom kept trying to
give them to me as dessert
it has sugar in it
no well so like one of the most one of
the most like pervasive fermentations
across like eurasia is fermented cabbage
um yeah so you see it as like
in germany kimchi in korea
um
swankie or paukai uh across across china
uh
various variations on kislyakapusta uh
across uh more slavic speaking regions
so i mean that's a vegetable it's a
vegetable that accumulates sugar and uh
you know you can harvest it pretty
weight and then ferment it to make it
last the winter right
and what's what's the deal with the
process
is it just because it's
pre-refrigeration and
it's such an old
um tradition that they bury the that
whatever it is that they've fermented
yeah i've heard about that what's up
with what is that with that
yeah well i mean
i
that this is putting on my sort of
amateur anthropologist pat moore but um
you know one one can imagine situations
where if you're uh
you know huma humans free agriculture
and prehistory even like priest pre uh
permanent settlements
um
[Music]
where you uh you know forage or harvest
uh
vegetables or uh hunt for animals and
then to uh to keep them safe and keep
them away from scavengers once you've
already already got them
one of the best ways is to like dig a
hole and you know line the hole with
leaves or something like that and then
bury it and come back to it later okay
so that wasn't fundamental to the
fermenting so the process it doesn't
really do anything for the process
well so
burying burying underground does protect
things from oxygen so it excludes oxygen
um which
then knocks out a whole category of uh
spoilage microbes like molds um so
so i mean if we're talking about like
fermented fruits or vegetables um
that'll often be lactic acid bacteria um
and most lactic acid bacteria doesn't
doesn't need oxygen some of them um
don't like oxygen at all so if you so
this is a this is a way to tune
the microbial cocktail for what it is
that comes out the other end it's sort
of like cooperative micro farming
nudging it in a certain direction cool
very cool and so but wait a minute isn't
um what's the difference then between
fermented
cabbage and
pickled cabbage when i think of coleslaw
i think that it's pickled not fermented
is that am i wrong
yeah well so coleslaw i mean so so you
get into
here like a language thing so like
pickling can can mean fermenting so like
cucumber pickles are usually fermented
um but you can also pickle things by
adding just adding acids to them without
fermenting so um often often using
vinegar to pickle um i mean vinegar is
the product of another fermentation so
you're you know kind of
either are they doing fermentation or
having done fermentation and now using
it for something else um but yeah
pickling especially in uh
in america um there's a strong tradition
of like vinegar pickling uh not right so
so i can grow a grape
drink the grape juice the grape juice i
don't drink i can ferment it
and i can make wine and then i can
ferment the wine and make vinegar and i
can use the vinegar to ferment the
cucumber and make a pickle
it is it is truly the gift that keeps on
giving
[Laughter]
that's good that's good so all i need is
some some grapes
yeah some grapes and some sugar and uh
whatever wild yeasts and bacteria are
hanging out on their skins
wow that's it
yeah well why don't we why don't we go
to some q a here i mean
i was going to eat up the whole the
whole show but that this is a cosmic
queries after all and chuck you got the
questions i've never i haven't seen any
of these questions i don't think you
have either is that right
uh
ariel has not
so we're here to stump you that's what
we're trying to do okay i'll try my best
okay i go for a check all right so these
are all patreon patrons and um
basically let's go with um
k profit 32 who says hey
dr johnson why doesn't fermented food
make you sick
it is essentially spoiled food also what
is your take on kombucha it makes me
feel like garbage
okay thank you for your answer love you
have a nice day
oh man well so
so if we're talking about spoilage um
you know some of that has actual like
actually to do with safety um but then
some of it also has to do with just
definitions that we apply somewhat
somewhat subjectively so i mean if you
uh
if you smelled the smell of a like
beautifully fermented camembert cheese
um if you did not know it was supposed
to smell that way you would run away
from it because uh you know it's a
we had we had a magnet up at a shop i
used to work at that said what's that
smell it's either bad meat or good
cheese
so context is very important for this um
but also
some cheeses smell like gym socks too
you know yeah
there's a whole a whole uh lantern so
the gym socks you pick up with forceps
and take it to the washing machine or
it's cheese and you spread it on cracker
and eat it right
yeah yeah um and the stinkier the more
expensive somehow yeah yeah because it
has to be very carefully uh tended to
achieve that uh that quality yeah um so
yeah so some of it is just you know
aesthetic um
but uh
a lot of
a lot of fermentation is just stuff that
we've learned over thousands
or millions of years um to like
intentionally you know keep in the right
conditions and uh coax what bacteria or
fungi are growing on it um so that you
know from experience it is actually safe
for us
but what you're saying is it's been
trial and error historically
to eat some spoiled foods and it kills
you and other spoiled foods don't kill
you and they you develop a taste for it
so we have so
so there's a lot of dead humans
who gave their life so that we could eat
some stinky cheese precisely precisely
oh my gosh i mean think of it think of
it as a uh like you know millions to
billions of person hours of r d uh just
so we can get these that's that's what
it is
and so because if i put i remember you
do this experiment in elementary school
you take uh some slices of bread right
put some water in the bread bag and put
it under the sink right right and come
back in a week and it's mold growing on
it yeah and
and i pay top dollar for roquefort moldy
cheese and i'm going to eat the cheese
but i'm not going to eat the mold on the
bread but can i eat the mold on the
bread i mean would i say
this is tasty i would
that sounds like i'm taking that as a no
i don't i can't i'm not sure that would
be actually dangerous but um i
would not recommend it although well
there are some some broke four producers
do like intentionally bake breads that
become
uh
infected or uh cultured with penicillium
molds and then use that to sort of kick
start the
cheese fermentation well if you're if
you grow up in a household like mine and
you have a great grandmother who was
born at the turn of the last century
moldy bread just means this park gets
cut out
now
and now you got some good bread to eat
so tell me about kombucha kombucha yeah
well so kombucha is first of all wait
can you please what is it yes yes yeah
so so kombucha is uh i'm basically
fermented tea um more technically it's
uh you start with a sweetened tea so tea
and sugar and water um and then you use
a special culture of microbes called a
scoby a symbiotic colony of bacteria and
yeasts so it's uh
alcohol-producing yeasts and acetic acid
producing bacteria that all live
together and basically what happens is
that the yeasts in the in the scoby um
ferment the sugars in the sweetened tea
into alcohol and then the acetic
bacteria munch on that alcohol and
create acetic acid which you might also
know is vinegar
and the bacteria also make uh they call
them exo polysaccharides it's basically
like goop um so everything floats
together in this sort of like mushroom
looking uh cellulose-based raft
well wait so what chemical is
responsible for the hair that grows on
your chest after you drink this stuff
yeah and what chemicals
i'm guessing testosterone
and who wants to why what is this floor
well why it's uh it's a it can be when
made correctly tangy and fizzy and
delicious
really yeah i had it once my brother
served it to me once it was like i you
know i i didn't mind having it once
twice was not happening yeah there's um
yeah there's some bad renditions out
there but they're also very good uh
bring justin something so he paid money
for he paid real money for his stash so
you're saying that it is for so first of
all i heard i saw a video i didn't hear
i saw a video on youtube and the woman
on the video was trying to show us how
to make kombucha and her first step was
well you have to find somebody who has
kombucha so that you can get their scoby
yes
i was like wait a minute you don't get
to do that that's just like i'm gonna
show you how to be a millionaire the
first thing you have to do is find
somebody with a million dollars
come on now
okay so so ariel who is kombucha number
one who is that person who is it
there are a couple i mean so there's
some fermentations where like it'll just
happen if you uh if you like store it
correctly and some like kombucha or um
kefir is another is another one where
some colony was established many many
many many years ago and uh worked so
well that uh people
held onto it and and passed it so we
need a kombucha map where you can choose
where you get your way you get your
cocktail yeah yeah i think um i think
ben wolfe at tufts he's a microbiologist
who's pretty cool is doing a like
kombucha mapping thing so he might be
able to okay cool and so now all now
from a scientific standpoint you as a
doctor arielle
are all
a doctor of agricultural and
environmental chemistry not a medical
doctor
okay okay well okay that is clear that
don't worry don't worry if somebody has
a heart attack in a restaurant i will
not call you
i have i have given the heimlich
maneuver in a restaurant okay right
so no are any of the claims to these
these fantastical claims that uh
kombucha supposedly these benefits are
any of them true or is it more lure
well like but actually we need to take a
break right there but when we come back
we will find out from
ariel if kombucha has any health
benefits at all like is that where
you're going with that yeah okay
right when we come back start talk
cosmic aquarius
we're back star talk cosmic queries
chuck nice hey buddy
and i have dr ariel johnson who's making
her second appearance on star talk we
went into our rolodex
because she had first appeared live with
us on stage so thanks
again you back we're cosmic queries
pulling questions from our patreon
members and we left off with a question
about kombucha and i've only been
offered kombucha from health
from
food health people right
and they're making claims about it and
then i tasted it and i say okay i'm not
the risk reward there is not good enough
for me whatever is not helping me in
life
the taste of that is worse right so can
you could you just comment on why people
drink it and is it for flavor are they
expecting some magic
um healing to happen yeah i mean i mean
so personally like i'm pretty skeptical
of any like claims that that any food uh
is a is a panacea um
you know as as
those are the kind of claims we get for
a lot of foods now except except kale
kale kill
come on ariel
kale
[Laughter]
okay so go on oh so um
so
to my knowledge there's been
a few but not extensive studies of uh
kombucha particularly as a as a
probiotic
um so you know our our guts are full of
bacteria we have more bacterial cells in
our body than human cells
um and uh we use them to help us digest
stuff and uh and stay healthy so uh
there's some idea that uh you know bears
out in data that kombucha can contribute
live bacteria that is uh helpful to your
gut um
i think i think some people do
do drink it out of a sense of
um you know kind of an elixir of of
health i'm not sure that's borne out by
any peer-reviewed science
um and a lot of people actually do drink
it for taste um especially as like you
know an alternative to soda uh you got
the fizz and the flavor but it's not
quite as uh sweet and
uh you know health destroying i'm just
saying if there's a lemonade in front of
me and kombucha i'm reaching for the
lemonade right that's fair no that's
totally fair i mean when um well i was
working at noma um uh the restaurant in
copenhagen we actually did a lot of uh
it's like one of the most famous
restaurants in the world very very yes
yes okay
um
so i was working there as uh yeah i had
we had a fermentation lab um but we made
a lot of kombuchas specifically for the
menu for flavor um so we'd use things
like elderflower or like heirloom apples
and things like that and would uh you
know transform them to become quite
acidic and uh and tasty for things uh
yeah so it is definitely a a flavor
thing as well so if you're basically a
food chemist that's really what you yeah
yeah so i mean my my like track uh was
food and wine chemistry and my
dissertation focused on flavor chemistry
and that's mostly what i do now i mean
sort of public uh
flavor chemistry yeah yeah yeah that is
that is the best use of science
in a long time let me just tell you
right now
that is that is stellar
okay
all right give me another one chuck here
we go this is matt
matt hairfield and matt says i've heard
about elephants and other mammals
becoming intoxicated from consuming
fermented fruit
how common is fermentation in the wild
and what causes it are mammals the only
ones who partake
well good question it's an excellent
question um yes
by the way let me just very quickly um
there's a very cool um
uh alcoholic squirrel in my neighborhood
and you cannot you and we only see him
at halloween
and it may have it may be a family like
father or son going down the line
because
year after year we had to stop leaving
the pumpkins out because the squirrel
you know you leave the pumpkin out for a
while a week later the pumpkin's still
out there squirrel comes up eats the
pumpkin and then you just see him kind
of like wobbling around and maybe he's
just wobbling around the neighborhood
like yo what's up what's up
hey what's up hey what's up
hey can i you got any lucy's can i get a
dollar for some cigarettes
can i get a dollar for some cigarettes
so anyway go ahead chuck lives in the
zoo philadelphia zoo
well so
pretty much any fermentation we do
intentionally now started as like an
accident or just sort of like the course
of uh
of nature and you know the microbiome of
wild microorganisms that are out living
on things so um
yes spontaneous spontaneous for
fermentation of fruits happens like all
the time um
you know we're able we're able to make
wine because uh the yeasts that create
alcohol actually live on the skins of
grapes i mean now a lot of wine is made
with inoculated yeast but um for you
know most of the history of wine which
goes back
at least eight thousand years um wow was
that was a
a wild fermentation with this yeast that
was just but is there is there enough
okay so the first fermentation is the
yeast turning the grape sugars into
alcohol so if is there enough alcohol in
a fermented fruit
to
make
mammals go shit-faced just oh yeah just
by yeah i mean you know even uh
even a fruit that gets to like two or
three percent alcohol and many fruits
can get much more alcoholic than that uh
if you're a small enough animal or you
eat enough of it uh can can make you
quite tipsy
i've also heard the stories about
elephants i think there was a um there
was like a tick tock video going around
of a pigeon that had eaten too many
fermented apples and was just sort of
like
lying
right face planted on the ground yeah
that was chuck's backyard
every animal in my backyard is
absolutely
plastered okay i think i think it might
be feeding them intentionally for the uh
comedic effect
okay so you don't have to be mammal
because birds aren't mammals no yeah
yeah um
i
i'm speculating here this is getting
getting sort of to the outer reaches of
my specific knowledge but um i mean you
know ethanol ethyl alcohol the product
of alcoholic fermentation you know acts
on central nervous systems and uh many
animals central nervous systems have a
lot of stuff in common so um
you know
especially vertebrate animals
yeah i mean other molecules like
nicotine um from from tobacco work on
you know various animals nervous systems
uh including like insects actually um
but they don't they don't have it okay
but yeah so um i would imagine most most
mammals can get plastered from from fun
fruit wow okay nice all right all right
give me another one shoot i'm ready to
go get drunk with an elephant
elephant
all right this is uh
this is uh luke uh what did the elephant
start telling jokes
where does a 900 pound human sit
[Laughter]
it's the 900 pound human in the middle
of the room guys
i feel like they'd be very cuddly um
that might be that might be fun yeah
let me tell you something that's the
scariest thing i've heard is an elephant
trying to cuddle you
let me tell you i i just see shades of
mice and men
anyway uh luke uh jabicki
luke chubbicki says this or gabiki one
or the other he says i have a jar of
pickled sausages that says it never
needs refrigeration
how does that work without spoiling is
it safe to eat and for how long
so
that's a great question because
sometimes you think that those jars say
that because they are vacuum packed
and that it doesn't need refrigeration
for storage but once you open it perhaps
you do but what is the difference or
for me i've never seen anything in
vinegar that said must refrigerate so
vinegar
yeah acetic acid is quite toxic to most
microorganisms that's the active acid in
vinegar
yeah yeah okay um so so acetic acid
itself is quite toxic and the low ph um
also inhibits
most most microbes
uh so it's like so really it really is
just a natural preservative
yeah definitely um i mean if it's a if
it's a jar i i don't i can't tell if
it's just to be clear but just to be
clear so high acid gives you the low ph
so that yes one in the six ph
it's not high acid and low ph that is
the same thing well actually so
technically getting into some chemistry
the acetic acid molecule only about like
one in ten thousand of them actually is
acidic the rest stays like fully uh
fully fully together non-dissociated and
and non-acidic so the ones that give up
a hydrogen ion or a proton to create a
low ph or acidity um
that creates an inhospitable environment
for spoilage microbes but the whole
undissociated non-acidic acetic acid
molecule itself uh is is also toxic i
think it interrupts the cell membrane of
oh interesting but that wouldn't then
trigger the the the litmus score
for it even if it is preservative
actually i see so okay so the acidity is
not a direct measure of how much acetic
acid is in it you need activated
molecules yeah well i mean there's like
every every acid has its natural balance
that it will that it will go into
yeah
cool
so uh when he says how does that work we
just you just said that
is it how long
is it safe to eat something that is
stored that way
um
well i mean so when you're when you're
talking about especially like uh
preserved meats and things you're
getting into a concept called water
activity uh so like the more the more
acid the more salt uh the more sugar you
have the lower the available water is so
i mean that's why uh
jam which is just like you know
spoilable fruits that you've added a lot
of sugar to can sit uh in your cupboard
for you know a year uh because there's
just not enough free water for microbes
to to do their thing interesting i mean
with stuff like that there's probably
a best part so that's why that's why
dried dried like beef jerky jerky
exactly exactly beef jerky it's lost all
liquid or dried salmon or any of that
yeah lots of charcuterie and salumi um
you know things like pepperoni or uh
capicola
uh either whole mussels sorry uh ariel
i'm sorry i'm from philadelphia it's not
capital sorry sorry gabagula thank
[Laughter]
nobody would ever let me live down
capicola i can't i can't let that happen
well let me invert the question what do
you know
is not turned off by
the
high acid vinegar solution that would
still grow regardless oh that's cool
yeah just to invert the question
um
i mean you know there's there's plenty
of like extremophile microbes out there
um
yeah high acid or high salt um
you know for for the most part if you're
adding a lot of salt to stuff that
excludes most most microbes but then
like soy sauce which usually ferment it
like 12 to 20 percent salt which is like
super high
um
there's an extremophile yeast called
zygosaccharomyces roots eye that like
loves that level of salt and actually
contributes to the flavor um that's a
bad ass name
let me let me hear that again did you
say it again
zygo sakara micey's rooksy eye man nice
you know what you just sound like you
casted a spell on
[Laughter]
that was totally that was a witch cat
that was a witch spell right there
exactly thank you
so now when you say that um that that
bacteria uh loves it and adds to the
flavor so
will it ultimately spoil the soy sauce
or does it just enhance the soy sauce
that one's generally not a spoilage
microbe okay i suppose like
it just produces like alcohol and flavor
molecules
um off the top of my head i can't think
of any really significant
like high acid high salt tolerant
to my cribs um a real microbiologist
might be mad at me right now for uh for
not identifying one but um
mostly you don't have like a ton to
worry about and like what you should be
looking out for for like unrefrigerated
things possibly going bad would be like
off
smells that shouldn't be there or like
visible mold um
yeah that's that should always be a sign
[Laughter]
i don't have a degree in anything
chemistry but i'm pretty sure that's a
good sign you don't need it well i mean
you know up until up until past year
that's how everyone knew that uh that
something was going bad yeah it's just
like hmm this bread is hairy yeah all
right
i'm gonna pass
all right cool smart all right give me
another one before we can go to break
okay all right hi ariel hi neil often we
hear of uh the words firm but they
didn't say hi to you chuck they did not
oh that's cold yeah this that is cold
okay who is it who's the person um you
know what here's the thing they don't
even
oh nope here it is their their their
name was on the previous page it's uh
avinov
abraham
so okay avena of abraham who clearly
doesn't like me
but you know what
you know what
i i read everybody's question that
doesn't make a difference how you feel
about it it's so sweet of you
i'm the joe biden of cosmic queries
okay here we go hi ariel hi neil often
we hear of the words fermentation with
regards to preserving food and making
alcohol with the help of microorganisms
but what precautions are needed to take
with respect to the fermentation process
so that the next time i'm making my
homemade wine i don't end up creating
some super bug that
that that will uh uh further harm this
current scenario or ferment the world
actually uh we we just ran out of time
but we'll come back in the third segment
we'll lead off with the answer to that
question on star talk cosmic queries the
fermentation edition
we're back cosmic rays food and
fermentation what does it all mean why
do we do it
uh and we just blame ariel for
everything that's happening yay
ariel uh again welcome back to our star
talk family for this show chuck always
good to have you here oh it's a pleasure
and so ariel we we left off with someone
asking about
yeasts gone wild i guess you know how to
you know you can use it for some purpose
some contain purpose but could they
mutate could they become an infectious
bug
there's all this fermenting going on
where we think we're in control of the
microbes but maybe one day the microbes
will fight back rise up
[Music]
well um
for
this is well outside the scope of the
time that we have for anyone that's
interested in getting into that much
more like philosophically uh heather
paxson is a uh
science and technology studies scholar
at mit and has really interesting work
on what she calls microbiopolitics um
that that talks a lot about whoa that's
a thing that's a phrase yeah yeah um
so uh but getting getting back to the
subject of the question well so
microorganisms are constantly mutating
and evolving um i mean you know random
mutation is what drives evolution uh and
and microbes are constantly
uh you know mutating and swapping genes
and trying new stuff out to like better
adapt to their environments um so that's
just gonna happen anyway as as we are as
we are currently all living yes as a
reality yeah we are right now
determining our fitness for this
particular environmental stress and i
just have to clarify something because
it's it's a common
uh misconception it's not that the
bacteria are
trying
to survive
by experimenting it's that they are
always experimenting right and if you
have a change in the environment it
kills everything that can't survive it
yes and so it's not like oh the
environment chains let me adapt no
nothing adapts
there's always built in some variation
and you live or die and the species
adapts but the organism does not i guess
that's the point i want to make drawing
here thank you okay good no that's a
good yeah
random mutation is always happening it's
often bad for organisms but occasionally
it's randomly good
um although some microbes do engage in
horizontal gene transfer um i don't
think there's any that sounds painful
i don't think there's any like choosing
of what's good there
chuck give me some of your genes yeah
i'm only in the vertical gene transfer
okay i'm just letting you know that
it's good to know your uh your
boundaries
so so what could happen
uh
yeah i mean
so yes yeasts yeast will mutate um
but
uh i i think probably in the course of a
fermentation that you're doing at home
or in a winery uh probably nothing's
gonna mutate to become like totally
crazy and outside the bounds of anything
you see right and escape the winery and
then yeah then we have maps of the zones
you know it would be like like you know
world war z except for microbes yeah um
i mean if that were to happen in your
homemade wine it would happen on a piece
of fruit out in the wild just as just as
easily so uh if that's a scenario that
will happen we're screwed anyway um but
uh i mean so chuck you get her her
answer is don't panic
everything is fine there's nothing wrong
okay exactly
very cool
i mean actually with the with with in
terms of like precautions for homemade
wine like
what's more likely to happen is that the
like balancing like that will
shift oh and your wine will taste like
crap that's what's really good
so i mean
even even if you add like one strain of
yeast to to something or one straight of
bacteria the the fermentation is going
to involve many different species kind
of forming and whole ecological system
uh in what you're doing so with uh with
wine
probably what's more likely to happen is
that a a wild yeast
um like britanomyces or a a bacteria
will
you know stay on for the ride and
possibly make some off flavors you don't
want or if the wine is to expose the
oxygen then you're gonna get uh acetic
acid turning it into vinegar right
um
yeah i mean generally alcoholic
fermentations aren't
super high risk right
okay so um so we're safe continuing to
make wine in your basement i think it's
good yeah without anything
if it gets moldy throw it out yeah so
but now speaking of that so what is
mulled wine then is it actually wine
yeah is it actual mold i've heard this
mold
mulled wine m-u-l-l-e-d
right close to m-o-l-d well i mean
multiplying okay chuck just got the
wrong word so you don't have to answer
them
[Music]
although although rice wines all start
with a
cultured mold uh usually an aspergillus
species that has been mostly
domesticated right yeah so what is
mulled wine though
with a u or with an o no with the you i
mean the
the real one the real wine that they
call mold run mold yeah um it's wine
that you uh heat up and add spices and
sometimes fruit too so i guess okay so
that's what makes it okay i got it yeah
so it's uh
uh you know the heat probably and even
the you know spices have antimicrobial
compounds so that would probably make it
even less susceptible to molds with an o
then okay and just while we're on the
subject of homemade uh microbes tell me
about sourdough bread
yeah well so sourdough before the advent
of commercial yeasts um most most breads
had something like a sourdough starter
uh sourdough is just a mixture of yeasts
lactic acid bacteria and acetic bacteria
all of which can kind of live in in wet
greens
um and by you know feeding them some
flour and some some water and letting
them do their thing they uh they add
some nice flavors to a dough that you
make uh but more importantly they create
carbon dioxide as one of their waste
products um so by uh kind of tending
tending this uh
farm of of mixed microbes you can cause
uh cause your bread to rise in the oven
um as you would with a commercial yeast
but with more with more flavors okay
okay so a little more flavorful and
complex i guess that's it yeah all right
so wait some people will say oh here's a
sourdough from a recipe for my great
great grandmother
um who cares why does that matter
well so i mean like
one aspect of it is that um why is that
a boast is that when is it like how you
feel so you start with a starter that
you're constantly feeding um so kind of
keeping it like an animal uh in in the
zoo so you're constantly you know every
every day or every several days adding
adding flour and water to it um so so
when you when you choose to do that um
how much it has fermented from the
previous batch before you add more how
much you throw out or like uh
incorporate and then how does this
purify the strain
when you do this over generations and
generations i mean it's it's always
it's like pretty dynamic so once uh when
you first add flour and water to a
starter there's more like i think more
yeast activity going on and then as it
gets older and more mature it'll get
more and more acidic
um so so then when you when you feed it
and then when
the like number of hours that you let
pass before between feeding and actually
making it into bread can have like a
huge effect on flavor and rise so so the
protocol that you follow that your
grandmother figured out um can actually
be a pretty big deal so this is a new
title of a movie the sourdough protocol
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right give me another one here's a
joy pinero denise who says this
uh i love you guys dr tyson dr johnson
oh and dr nice okay see ya she's made up
for she made up for
the other one yeah thank you yeah so
take that aniva
she goes
my question is given the state of the
world when it comes to land shortage for
growing crops is there a way to
genetically produce an easily grown
hearty crop with high yield that
contains the perfect amount of vitamins
and minerals amino acids and proteins
basically a living version of what they
eat in on the nebuchadnezzar hovership
in the matrix
yes by the way she says i know that's
neil's favorite movie thank you so much
so that's the scene where this it comes
out of the spigot and it looks kind of
like as they say in the movie it looks
like a pile of snot and they're eating
it they said oh it's got all the amino
acids and vitamins that the healthy body
needs so i'm curious it tastes like
tasty wheat right take that yes
i've been watching a lot of movies in
quarantine or re-watching so ariel
well one other point here in the movie
deep impact okay i don't won't get into
the details but there's a scene where
there's someone offloading they're
getting ready for the end of the world
someone offloading these groceries and
they're full of
uh little cans of ensure
and so
if i understand it the cans of insurer
which are typically eaten by older
people
are have all the protein and vitamins
and minerals and carbohydrates you need
and and they come in a can so they don't
have to be refrigerated so if the world
is going to end you want to fill your
groceries you know don't leave the
toilet paper alone the other way you can
wipe yourself
um so mike a good question is is there
some garden
mixture of
of
foods
uh let's assume you can't
raise a cow so garden mixture of
vegetables where
at a minimum size one person can live
off of that
oh was that the
so two questions
one
one is the one is the crop one is the
product the engineering of the crops and
the minimum the minimum amount of garden
space um
i am not really sure what the minimum
amount of garden space to translate into
edible calories and nutrients is um i
know that uh
uh for example like one one chestnut
tree might be able to
uh at maturity provide enough
carbohydrates to keep one person uh fed
for a year
um
i mean i
setting aside the apocalyptic scenarios
where you would actually just have to
have uh you know single cell protein
tasty wheat um generally the most like
nutritious and resilient systems that
you should be trying to doing uh to plan
for the apocalypse would be like fairly
biodiverse ones so like growing as many
plants together as possible um you know
humans humans are pretty uh interesting
in their ability to like get nutrition
from lots of different things uh you
know we're omnivores but we're like
omnivores that can make our diets out of
nearly anything so we interviewed the
creator and founder of soylent
this liquid and this is this one you
know it's your entire meal in a
in a cup yeah and it's people
it's the worst part of people
so what intrigued me was he can make the
exact ingredients that you need but he
wanted it to be
more
more friendly to the ecosystem and
wanted to
infuse it with sort of base amino acids
from the
as low on the food chain as he could go
and i was very intrigued by that as at
least as a as a as a goal yeah
oh i know i know there's a lot of people
interested in algae
for example exactly sources of both
proteins and and fats um because uh yeah
fats are actually pretty important
dietarily especially for eating a lot of
protein
right right yeah so there's there's
definitely a lot of research happening
on that okay
so we may
we we may be seeing a future where we uh
uh you know have gigantic tanks of algae
that we
uh that then harvest and
and eat
now now that's nasty
tanks of algae yeah please sir i mean
i've got some more yeah that would be
the most brutal version of the
future scenario that just kill me okay
i'm going on record just kill me
that's a thin gruel i never want to have
to eat yeah the word the word vat and
the word algae together in the same
sentence yeah so nasty
all right chuck we got time maybe for
one more question go all right let's get
to a chemistry question from douglas
stern who says has nasa used chemistry
to ferment foods that astronauts eat in
order to help them maintain better
health while visiting the international
space station or we're consuming
artificial supplements just be an easier
route live long and prosper oh nice
nice
so what do you know about the is i can
tell you what i know about it oh yeah i
know a little bit but you probably know
yeah there are enough supplied
ships to the iss they just wait for the
burger to come
well
no by the way they're they're getting
cosmic uber eats
they're getting cosmic uber eats at the
iss buddy
okay
no no space grubhub that's what we're
talking about it's the long-term voyages
where they're really thinking about this
where you don't have a supply chain to
it you know nine months to mars two
months on location
coming back you're away for three years
right so i yeah i'm so i don't know if
they're leaning towards just preserved
food or
you know salt preserved you know
desiccated food or or
um the the problem is liquid weighs a
lot yes relative to other things and so
if you need a big vat of your pickles
that would then it's liquid holding them
i don't know that that would be a first
choice right no i mean uh
i was i so on the subject i actually was
uh i guess in 2017 i went to a workshop
at uh johnson space center specifically
on like
open sourcing uh wait no kennedy in the
one in florida oh be kennedy space
center okay
um
about like sort of
what open source could do uh to to think
about food in food and space um so i
know that you know they're they're doing
plant growth experiments at nasa and
they will actually like bring up seeds
and water and grow uh you know four
tomatoes and one strawberry and that
will be your uh
i mean obviously not a big nutritional
component it's a start
it's good for
and it's much better than a poop potato
although i don't know after after like
you know however many weeks i think
those poop potatoes would start looking
pretty good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah pinocchio says in the original book
hunger makes the best sauce indeed wow
wow i love that yeah yeah
um
so i mean so in terms of like
fermentation um i don't think
uh i don't think nasa is doing much with
with fermentation if only because they
try to not send as many
any microbes up into space they try to
sterilize things uh right right right
examination okay that's very very very
important and excellent point i i would
think but but uh we got to wrap this up
let me end with it with a question is
there are there fermentative
um is there a frontier of fermentation
where you'll show up one day here's a
newly fermented thing that didn't
previously exist in the food catalogs
here
is it do your you and your people do
those kinds of experiments inventing
foods yeah well i've i've actually um
done some work i have uh i have friends
at a company called ginkgo bioworks uh
they are a like synthetic biology
startup they may have surpassed startup
phase they're doing quite well um but uh
so what they do is engineer microbes uh
to do interesting things um and
uh they they had some cool strains of uh
of yeasts uh some yeasts that were
producing uh carotenoids um which are
orange pigments in
in in flowers and grass and carrots that
are actually the precursors to a lot of
interesting like fruity flavors um and
then also yeasts that were producing
flavor molecules specifically uh so
okay so chuck what's she saying there is
that nature is insufficient
there's some flavors we need there's
some food we're just doing do it
ourselves yeah right so um so there i i
and their creative director uh christina
aguipakis who's pretty awesome um got
together and we're making some fermented
foods with these totally brand new uh
you know super
flavor molecule producing strains okay
so if you are don't exist the next time
we invite you it's because it's one of
those experiments
right well we'll have created the uh the
super bug but it's like try this
all right we got we gotta end it there
unfortunately but uh ariel johnson very
delighted to have you back oh delighted
to be here uh thanks for all the great
questions
we'll surely find another excuse to
bring you back i certainly hope so chuck
i'm glad we now uh can pronounce words
correctly as they do in philadelphia yes
yeah i i still can't pronounce names
correctly but at least we know that
capicola is gabagoo
for life
all right this has been cosmic queries
their fermentation edition i'm neil
degrasse tyson always
to keep
[Music]